hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we'll be discussing some of the many
portraits hanging within the hallowed
Halls of Hogwarts School of Witchcraft
and Wizardry while I suppose the exact
number of portraits lining the walls of
this famous building is somewhat
debatable many subjects have more than
one portrait and who knows what secret
portraits may hang in closets long
forgotten there are around 60 portrait
subjects that we do know about over the
course of a few videos we'll cover each
and every one of them diving into who
the witch or wizard was why they have a
portrait hanging up in Hogwarts and
anything else of node today we'll kick
things off alphabetically which brings
us to the portrait of a wizard who needs
no introduction Alba stumbledore as many
of you will know Albus Dumbledore was
the eldest son of Percival and Kendra
Dumbledore a wizard in Witch of
primarily magical descent he grew up in
the Wizarding community of mold on the
walled and went on to become one of the
most powerful and well-respected with
acids to ever live in modern times his
portrait was made soon after his
appointment as Headmaster at Hogwarts in
the year 1956 once completed Dumbledore
kept it secure and recovered in the
headmaster's office within the school it
is said that Dumbledore would visit his
portrait often as the more time one
spends with their painted likeness the
more characteristics and personality
traits the portrait is able to take on
during these sessions it's likely that
Dumbledore also passed along much of his
wisdom and plans for Harry Potter as his
portrait provided much support and was
invaluable to Severus Snape after Albus
had passed and Snape assumed the
position of Headmaster at the school the
portrait now hangs among the other
former Hogwarts and Masters in the
headmaster's office Ambrose SWAT Ambrose
SWAT was an 18th century Professor who
eventually became one of Hogwarts
Headmasters it is rumored that before
becoming Headmaster he spent time as a
friar which would support the accounts
that SWAT was their very Pious wizard it
was incredibly passionate about the
study of Religion in fact there's a
motto inscribed on one of his portraits
within Hogwarts which reads Aura a
labora which is Latin for pray and work
the motto of the Benedictine order now I
say one of his portraits because Ambrose
SWAT indeed has two paintings of his
likeness hanging up in Hogwarts the
first portrait is of a younger version
of The Wizard in which he's wearing a
suit it can be found along the Walls
Within the grand staircase the second is
Ambrose's Headmaster portrait presumably
painted upon him taking the position as
was tradition this painting can of
course be found within the headmaster's
office alongside Hogwarts other former
Headmasters both young and old portraits
are known for their Pious inclinations
and typically spend their time
performing some form of religious act
such as praying or reading a religious
Doctrine Anne Berlin the presence of
Anne boleyn's portrait within Hogwarts
may come as a surprise eyes to many
however the former Queen of England and
second wife of the infamous muggle King
Henry VII had quite the reputation
within the Tuda court with many
suggesting that she must have been a
witch to have captured the love of their
married King by contrast within the
Wizarding Community there were rumors
that Anne was in actual fact as squib a
descendant of a magical family but
without any powers herself
regardless of whether or not any of that
was true and blood status and true
Heritage remain a mystery beheaded at
the orders of her husband after only
three years of marriage it's no wonder
that Anne boleyn's portrait which hangs
within the grand staircase near the
second floor is a rather anxious one it
is said that she will talk to anyone who
passes by about Henry's lessening of
factions and that she is rather fond of
the female students Ariana Dumbledore
the younger sibling of Albus Dumbledore
Ariana had a very troubling childhood in
which she was attacked by a group of
Muggles while she was innocently playing
with magic at the mere age of six as a
result Ariana tragically became an
obscurial A young witch who was so
affected by the trauma of her attack
that she became intensely ashamed of her
powers suppressing them to the point
that her magic became incredibly
dangerous sadder still Ariana died as a
girl during a dispute between Albus
their brother aberforth and garlic
Grindelwald the true detail tells of her
death remain a mystery to this day
due to her condition Ariana never
attended Hogwarts however Abba forth
hung her porched up at the hog's head in
in hogsmeade which conceals a secret
passage into Hogwarts room of
requirement her likeness remains rather
shy and does not talk to those she does
not know Armando dip it Headmaster of
Hogwarts during the 1940s The Ripe old
age of 300 and something Professor
Armando dipit was the Headmaster of the
school immediately preceding Albus
Dumbledore Tom Riddle who of course
later became Voldemort was a student
during Professor dibbett's tenure as
Headmaster it was during this time that
Tom reopened the Chamber of Secrets and
subsequently framed rubius Hagrid for
the crime resulting in Armando expelling
an innocent young Hagrid as a former
Ravenclaw himself Professor dippit's
portrait depicts him in blue and bronze
robes which of course hangs in the
headmaster's office
Barnabas the balmy Barnabas the bombing
was a wizard who attempted and quite
obviously failed to train trolls to
perform ballet it is said that after he
attended Hogwarts as a pupil he went on
to become a professional theatrical
wizard although the rumors suggested he
found success in his career he was
somewhat obsessed with putting on a show
that no one in the Wizarding World would
ever forget presumably this is what led
to his absurd attempt to teach trolls
how to dance on the seventh floor of
Hogwarts across the hall from the
entrance to the room of requirements
hangs a tapestry depicting Barnabas the
balmy in his effort to train trolls in
The Art of Dance
basil fronzak Professor basil fronzak
was the Headmaster at Hogwarts sometime
before Armando Depots evidently he was
an incredible scholar who had a passion
for knowledge and learning he has at
least two portraits hanging up within
the school at present one of which is of
course he said Master painting which is
displayed in the headmaster's office
alongside his fellows there is also at
least one other which used to hang
within the grand staircase but was later
relocated to The Dungeons of the castle
it's unclear how many more portraits of
battle hang on the grand staircase and
surrounding area at present his portrait
which was relocated to the dungeons used
to protect a shortcut from the grand
staircase to a second floor Corridor
near the library his password to gain
access was rumored to be studious
success apparently upon his relocation
to the dungeon his portrait was once
again charged with guarding another
secret passageway this time to the grand
staircase it said the password to this
shortcut was libraries Liberate the
Bloody Baron as many of you will know
the Bloody Baron is one of the ghosts
who roam the halls of Hogwarts at
present but as it turns out this
particular ghost also has a portrait
hung upon the walls of the school as a
former student of Hogwarts back in the
11th century the Bloody Baron was a
Slytherin pupil who attended the school
soon after it was founded at some point
in his youth he became infatuated with
Helena Ravenclaw the daughter of one of
Hogwarts Founders Marina Ravenclaw after
Helena ran away to the Albanian Forest
Rowena charged the body Baron with
finding her daughter and bringing her
back home tragically when Helena refused
the bloody Baron's request to return
home with him he became enraged and
murdered her devastated by what he'd
done he in turn killed himself the two
returned to Hogwarts to haunt the Halls
as the ghost of Ravenclaw otherwise
known as the gray lady and the Ghost of
Slytherin respectively as for his
portrait the Bloody Baron is represented
by an arrangement of pictures in four
parts known as a tetraptic these
paintings hang in the Dungeons and
together create a singular image of the
baron dressed in red and unsheathing his
sword from its Scabbard Brian gagwild
III the final portrait I'll be covering
in today's video is of Brian gagwild III
a pure blood descendant of Hogwarts
Headmaster Brian gagwell the first
although he was never had Master himself
throughout the 17th century Brian was a
huge supporter of education and was
instrumental in the efforts to provide
all Wizarding children with access to
schooling outside of their own home in
honor of his support institutionalized
education Hogwarts has several portraits
of Ryan gagwell III hung throughout the
school's main hallways as he also has a
portrait within Malfoy Manor which he
frequently visits he's not always the
easiest portrait subject to track down
and with that we've come to the end of
another video what did you think would
you like to learn more about the history
of Hogwarts portraiture please share
your thoughts in the comments below and
as always if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
the channel until next time remember it
does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live